one of the keys to a healthy lawn is
directly tied to something you're gonna
do a lot in that's mow it's very
important we tell people when they're
maintaining a healthy lawn is to let
that lawn be as high as you can
after your mowing okay so we're telling
people to set the mower up as high as
it'll go and a lot of times that's right
around three inches now the other part
about mowing high is if you're following
the one-third rule which means you're
never going to remove more than a third
of the tissue
every time you mow what it means is when
you're keeping your grass at 3 inches
you can let it go to about 4 or 4 and a
half inches before you have to mow it
now that means on the average lawn
you're mowing once every 10 to 14 days
when you're mowing nice and hot now
MOLLE nice and high let's the roots go
really deep and they outcompetes the
weeds for light and nutrients in water
the other part about this is if you have
the device to measure you can do
something like this or you can just use
your hand stick it into the canopy get a
measure and you can see the distance on
your hand here is the height of cut and
you can see that before and after
the height that you're mowing at once
you have a height adjustment that works
for you and you figure out you know
exactly what 3 inches looks like what
we've done is we've just created a
little piece of tape here so whoever's
mowing knows that we just set the mower
to right above the tape and that gives
us the height adjustment we're looking
for just a little tip to keep things
consistent ok we've just finished mowing
we brought the turf down to about three
and a half inches now and one of the
benefits of following the one-third rule
is that it really helps you with
cleaning up the clippings now this mower
here is not equipped with a mulching
device it's just a side discharge unit
but because we're mowing frequently they
don't clump up on the surface and they
return adding nutrients and organic
matter in the soil
you